the libertarians who I'm afraid will be
disappointed in November we'll you know
look at the Free State Project as a ways
that they can actually go and make a
difference at a smaller level with more
impact hi I'm Nicholas V with reason TV
and today we're talking with Matt
Phillips he's the president of the Free
State Project which has succeeded in its
initial goal of getting 20,000 people to
pledge to move to New Hampshire and
create a modern Galt's Gulch that
actually works so Matt thanks for
talking to reason good to be here
earlier this year you guys you hit the
20,000 mark so that begins something
called the great migration talk a little
bit about what the timeline is for
people moving there and then what are
they gonna do when they get there so
people pledge to move within five years
of hitting that 20,000 number and we've
already got 2,000 that have already
moved in advance over the last several
years and another 2,500 who already
lived there who have signed the same
statement of intent so we're now in the
process of going and calling the
remaining 18,000 and growing people to
say hey we triggered the move you know
do you need resources can we connect to
you help you figure out where you're
gonna live get you a job and and the
Free State Project has been around for
over a decade now so you have a
community a network of people and and
helpers right yeah
it was formed in 2001 Jason Soren's
wrote the original article proposing the
idea by 2003 they had selected New
Hampshire as the as the destination and
then it's just been slowly organically
growing since then the Free State
Project people have had significant
impact on New Hampshire talk about some
of the highlights so far and then what
you're hoping to see you know by the end
of this year or over the next year or so
there's something like 18 Free Staters
who are state reps in New Hampshire that
have had a variety of legislative wins
off the top of my head we got rid of all
the knife laws in New Hampshire so it
was illegal to carry there there were
various laws about about types of knives
and how when you can carry them and
there is now known no law on the books
referring to knives in New Hampshire
several years ago
we reduced the state budget by 10%
former president of the Free State
Project Carla Garrick had a really
landmark court case in New Hampshire
that affirmed the right to film the
police in public then there's a lot of
out of system activism where people are
you know trading with Bitcoin and having
a community market days and you know
getting together as families so there's
there's a good mix of activism that
people are doing in your intro how does
the Free State Project Interest
intersect with you know the 2016
election like will you guys be doing
stuff in New Hampshire that will you
know about national politics or is it
local politics
so the Free State Project itself is a
501c3 nonprofit so we we can't endorse
candidates or active legislation but
many of the people who are there because
the Free State Project are involved both
at the national and the state and local
level and they're either running for
office directly themselves or they're
supporting candidates who are or they're
volunteering with organizations like
Americans for Prosperity that are doing
various campaign you know issue based
campaigns around things like right to
work are you guys going to get rid of
State on liquor stores in New Hampshire
that would seem like an easy an easy win
it would be except for the fact that it
also provides a huge amount of revenue
for the state and we actually sell more
more booze per capita than any of the
states around us so a lot of people
cross over the border to buy because
even though it's a monopoly it's still
cheaper because of the lower taxes yeah
that's fascinating
tako you became the president of the
Free State Project earlier this year
talk about your work history where did
you come from and how did you come to to
be a libertarian so I I went to
Princeton where I got a degree in
politics but while I was there I intern
at his summer internship at the Cato
Institute in DC which is actually how I
met Jason Soren's he and I were were
fellow interns together so I you know
was studying politics but I was writing
about technology so my senior thesis was
on cryptography and privacy and after I
graduated I went to work
in New York City at double-click the
online online internet advertising
pioneer and I worked there for about
four years and then left with a
colleague to co-found another company
called Wright media to basically do a
real-time auction marketplace for online
advertising and I did that for four
years and then I caught bought by Yahoo
in 2007 so I took some time off and was
casting around trying to figure out what
I was gonna do next my life I wanted to
do something that would be
intellectually challenging but also you
know maybe help make the world a better
place and I started going to some
various libertarian conferences I went
to the reason Cruz we were just talking
about in 2012 and then I went to a
Liberty forum in 2013 and and that's the
winter event of the Free State Project
that's our annual winter event up in
Manchester and you know I had signed the
statement of intent ten years ago right
when I was starting my company and so I
was like okay New Hampshire I can't I
can't deal with that right now that's
forward ten years I went up there not
really knowing what to expect and was
just blown away by how many people there
were and how much excitement and energy
and buzz and I started to think oh wow
maybe this is something that I've got a
you mentioned you were an intern in
college at Cato so did you show up to
college libertarian and if so what's
your libertarian origin story the
earliest the earliest thing I can point
to is that in high school as a public
speaking exercise all the seniors had it
had to give a short speech and one of my
classmates gave a talk about hemp
regulation not not about the marijuana
drug side of it just about the
industrial side of it and I think that
sort of sparked a little question of
like yeah hey wait a minute why that
doesn't make any sense why do we do that
you know a lot of libertarians and we're
speaking here at Freedom Fest and a lot
of libertarians are either super
optimistic about the future or terribly
pessimistic and you know the future the
country's been ruined since 1789 or
something you're more of an optimist
what what obviously the Free State
Project is you know creating liberty or
freedom in or a lifetime as part of the
slogan goes but why are you optimistic
and you know and where where does that
lead you yeah I'm optimistic you know
what we're doing in New Hampshire I get
to see sort of day in day
I get emails from people that are you
know say hey I'm moving so I see what
that what we're doing is really on the
cusp of starting to generate some pretty
exciting results and that affords me the
luxury of not worrying so much about
what's happening the disaster that's
happening at the national level
regardless of who wins or loses come
this fall we're still gonna be doing
what we're doing and hopefully you know
the libertarians who I'm afraid will be
disappointed in November we'll you know
look at the Free State Project as a way
that they can actually go and make a
difference at a smaller level with more
impact thank you very much thank you
Nick we've been talking with Matt
Phillips he's the president of the Free
State Project check it out online at
free state project org and move to New
Hampshire you won't be sorry for reason
TV I'm Nikolas